c'était fanny grandmont michèle dawe est
pas de journées bonsoir mon corps c'est
prévu ça peut prévu mais je vais jouer
un tour de table sur le confinement des
spas ça m'a beaucoup frappé claudy un
extrait tout cas je me souviens plus qui
exactement tout ça mais l'aïe était
temps les jeunes n'en peuvent plus ils
se cachent pour jouer au basket se cache
stéphanie grammond ce qu'on comprend
pour simplifier le chef fille l extrême
et il faut un peu parce que le com qui
tape aussi claire fin juin on peut
s'attendre qu'à peu près partout au
québec
les jeunes vont pouvoir rejouer au
soccer au baseball etc etc
cc c'est tant mieux on s'en serait
jamais de ça et et puis je pense à
manier qu'il faut aussi comprendre que
sa marine décédé règles en place si tout
le monde les bafouent donc vaut mieux
encadrer les choses convenablement et
puis s'assurer que les mesures sont
sanitaires sont respectées puisque lily
lesparre se fondant le dans l'ordre et
dans la sécurité
oui michel un petit mot là dessus sur
l'annoncé aujourd'hui bah écoutez c'est
celle attendue depuis très très
longtemps je peux en témoigner moi j'ai
trop aux trois sportifs la maison qui
trépigne depuis des semaines en
attendant à une annonce comme celle là
alors écoutez ça va faire du bien à tout
le monde
logée par les détaillants tate là je
sais pas dans quelle mesure le tout est
complètement des conflits mais 25 garder
une date en tête 25 juin ou en jaune on
va pouvoir avoir des contacts rapide ça
ça veut dire le soccer entre soccer sa
wii et écoutez je peux pas faire autre
chose que d'applaudir et
et j'aimerais jouer pour les origines
basques important par journée le support
jeu par la grand sportif là oui pis mais
moi je peux a touché par cette mesure là
mais je pense à mon oeuvre sa passion si
le circuit des limites au plaisir que tu
peux avoir à frapper le ballon sur un
mur ou à tirer dans un filet sans garder
moi juste avoir des pratiques lui donne
l'exemple du parc à côté de chez nous il
ya des enfants de 7 ou 8 ans qui
regardent les grands qui ont déjà pris
l'initiative de ce décor finir humaine
et qui jouent déjà démarche et ensuite
on va dire aux plus jeunes que eux ne
peuvent pas et doivent respecter les
règles
donc il était temps à partir du moment
où il ya des jeux indés confinement
volontaire malgré ce que vous voulez les
autorités était temps qu'on permette aux
jeunes de faire eux aussi ce que
certains grands fonds bon ben on respire
on respire le tunnel ce qu'on va arrêter
de l'appeler le troisième le débat porte
sur le tunnel je vous fais entendre
monsieur legault qui en chambre a voulu
renverser la pression doit vous les
libéraux là et c'est vous nous propose
exactement
madame à agla devons répondre et vous
allez entendre monsieur trudeau qui dit
moi m'a pas fait de demande de
financement comme chef de position
officielles viennent nous dit on veux
être très clair on y compte un tunnel on
y compte un pont mais on est pour être
aux miens n'existe pas encore de thé des
portes et des autos ou des personnes de
divers québec québec à lévis donc est ce
que la chef de l'opposition officielle
pour être plus clair
quelle est sa position le premier
ministre refuse de répondre
il présente un projet un projet qui est
aberrant qui est basée sur aucune étude
aucune étude n'a été démontrée rien
comme données en fait on peut même pas
interrogé le directeur du bureau de
projet parce qu'on ne l'a empêché à
trois reprises et le premier ministre
dit la position du parti libéral est
peut être pas clair elle est très claire
on est contre le tunnel qu'artiste elle
oui contre le projet de 10 milliards ce
que l'on veut savoir c'est sur quoi se
base cette idée
on va regarder on va travailler avec
avec les différentes provinces sur
différents projets on n'a pas encore
reçu de propositions de projets concrets
par rapport à ce troisième il y un mais
on va regarder en bonne et due forme
quand ça viendra
prudent et monsieur trudeau pas de
journée quand monsieur legault
violemment à glander dit l'objet de
comptes ou troisième lien pour la région
de québec ça peut faire mal aux libéraux
qui sont plus lents fait dans les gens
de québec
mais s'ils veulent revenir un jour sur
le plan national donka doit composer ce
pas facile non plus là pour le sur le
pour ce qui est des enjeux de la
capitale-nationale faut comprendre que
les libéraux ont fait une croix sur
plusieurs comptes et à commencer par
celui de lévis qui a pas si longtemps
pouvait passer d'une couleur à l'autre
si pulka les libéraux cible une petite
poignée de compter en gros jean-talon
gens de changer puis taschereau mais je
comprends que monsieur legault essai de
talonner maintenant anglade en me disant
qu'est ce que vous proposez est
actuellement la période de questions
c'est le gouvernement qui est
questionnée
mais monsieur je vous vois une faiblesse
dans la position de madame anglade dans
la mesure où les libéraux étaient sous
précédent gouvernement en faveur du
troisième bien cela dit on ne savait pas
où ce n'est pas encore officiel que les
coûts annexes y élever piste nouvelle
chef pour avoir une nouvelle position
puis ça monsieur leubou de défendre son
projet puis la première des choses
ça serait de rendre disponible le
directeur du bureau de projet pour qu'il
réponde aux questions si monsieur
legault est si confiant que son projet
est bon malgré le fait qu'aucun expert
l'appui peut-être que ça serait bien
l'entendre
le directeur du bureau de projet on n'a
pas depuis quoi ça fait quatre panels de
suite qu'on parle du tunnel c'est pas le
seul loin d'être terminée est-ce que
vous pensez que le grand legault je
posais la question martinière soit devra
bientôt chargé de stratégie être plus
transparents sortir des études sortir
des faits parce que là on tourne en rond
ouais ça fait depuis les années 60 qu'on
en parle alors c'est pas étonnant que
nous on en parle
plusieurs fois
oui ils savent à deux ça va devoir se
préciser mais honnêtement monsieur
legault le calcul qu'il faut c'est que
peu importe que ça crie un peu partout à
l'extérieur de la région de québec
ça leur ferait pas de pertes de vote
éventuellement
les libéraux peuvent aujourd'hui qui
dissipe de trois comtés à québec mais
dans la réalité des choses mais les
chances qu'ils réussissent en récupérer
ne serait ce qu'un sont extrêmement
faibles et sans monsieur legault le sait
et on voit les taux de satisfaction à
l'endroit de son gouvernement
il faut qu'on calcule que toutes les
raisons pour lesquelles les gens aiment
monsieur legault maintenant ne
disparaîtront pas parce que il ya
éventuellement un tunnel qui soit dit en
passant on le verra pas avant avant
d'entrer très longtemps les libéraux
écouter leur position ils avaient créé
un bureau d'études mais souvenez-vous à
l'époque on parlait d'un cadre financier
de l'ordre de 4 milliards dont un est
rendu à 10
il savait pas à l'époque qu'ils savent
pas plus maintenant ce qui est ce qu'ils
proposent heureusement pour eux le
plaisir qu'ils ont à prendre la décision
alors c'est facile de dire critiquer
mais honnêtement je sais pas ce qu'il
ferait si bon stéphanie une bonne façon
de monsieur vous détourner l'attention
le dieu libéraux parce qu'évidemment les
ont ils ont annoncé la semaine dernière
et le timing était plutôt mauvais parce
qu'en même temps on a vu qu'on était
obligé de fermer le pont de
l'île-aux-tourtes à montréal et ça ça
met en relief le fait qu'il ya un manque
d'entretien chronique dans toutes les
infrastructures à travers la province
ont payé 28 milliards qui manquent
si on voulait remettre demain matin
toutes nos infrastructures 1,9 donc elle
est évidemment les routes mais aussi les
écoles les hôpitaux et ce chiffre est
probablement sous-estimé donc là la
population voit le gouvernement durant
va mettre 10 milliards dans un nouveau
lié sans trop savoir si si si c'est
nécessaire
un projet
enfin nick qui voit et qui va qui vont
être réalisable sama pendant très
longtemps les deux ans mais les deux un
côté de l'option c est ce qu on en a
vraiment besoin est là monsieur monsieur
legault est un peu sur la défensive si
je faisais donc de remettre les
projecteurs sur sony libéraux c'est une
façon de façon de s'en sortir
ouais mais sur la défensive mais en même
temps gonflé par un appui important dans
l'opinion publique on a l'impression
comme dit michel que ça les empêche pas
tant que ça dormir je vous traduis bien
le chef doute pas la lisent ils à tulle
que dans le fond six auxquelles ils
voient plein critique mais nous on
poursuit là les gens qui tiennent aux
projets dans la grande région de québec
pour eux c'est très très important alors
que sur qui achètent et les gens dans la
région québec son compte mais on voit
plus de critiques à l'extérieur de la
capitale nationale et ceux qui sont
contre le troisième vient leur
opposition va être moins déterminante
dans leur choix de vote que l'appui de
ceux qui sont en faveur du troisième
lien puis ils disent que à montréal
toute façon ce qui va retenir
l'attention c'est la phase 2 du rem ou
tongs les l'auteur puis la pandémie et
toutes sortes d'autres enjeux donc ça
beau szabo grenier à montréal et
ailleurs au sujet du troisième lien dans
le 4 5 0 mais ça sera pas déterminant
pour le vote donc je pense que là la
coalition avenir québec la conscience
assez à cette différence du moins sur le
plan stratégique
c'est la même chose pour le projet gnl
québec mettons dans la région du
saguenay c'est très populaire et
monsieur legault appui projet en disant
bon mais ces gens là vont voter pour moi
à l'extérieur de la région tout le monde
est à peu près quand ça sera pas
déterminant
ouais mais génial ça risque mais ça
c'est moins mal et un gouvernement plus
qu'à cause de loin bon il faudra voir si
le qu'est ce qui arrive avec le fédéral
pour le pour ce qui est du troisième
ligne et parce que il ya quand même un
des montants importants le qui sont
supposés venir d'ottawa
sauf que le gouvernement fédéral c'est
loin d'être plein qui vont donner par
marchand que ça parce que ça cadre paul
dans le dans les programmes qu'ils ont
dans le projet de relance verte n'a que
qu'ils ont mis de l'avant dans le
dernier budget donc c'est aussi cette
année une certitude pour le pour le
troisième ligne oui parce que beaucoup
d'argent effectivement ventilation dans
les écoles thomas gerber notre collègue
ce matin refait un texte en anglais
non seulement le minet ce ne pouvait pas
dire ça il avait déjà sorti ça que la
santé publique avait validé le processus
de test dans les écoles ne peut pas
demander l'appui donc et mais cette
sacrée tour de tension ministère de
sorte que on s'est échangé la balle
qu'est ce que je réponds et ses appuis
la santé publique est en colère de se
faire instrumentaliser pour reprendre un
mot à la mode jeu on écoute on écoute
monsieur legault qui a défendu son
ministre
puis petit à petit et chargeant terminé
c'est marwari ski jean françois roberge
consulter la santé publique ni la peau
fait valider le lion je peux qu on
commence à jouer sur les mots s'est
effectivement il n'y a pas fait valider
sa méthode meilleur consulter puis
toutes les recommandations qu'on a reçue
de la santé publique ont été intégrés
il ya eu malentendu entre la santé
publique et l'éducation sur la manière
de qualifier la collaboration ce qui est
arrivé ce qui est un travail de
collaboration entre la santé publique
ministre à l'éducation j'ai déjà reconnu
de fait ne pas utiliser le terme validée
cette époque le terme à propos sommet
jack welch 6 cette semaine que c'est
déjà dissiper ce malentendu et une
petite nouveauté un matin par contre le
ministère de l'éducation québec a tenté
d'influencer le ministère de la santé
pour qu'il laisse croire que la santé
publique avait validé les thèses la
qualité de l'air à l'école alors que
c'était faux nous sommes que ça ça c'est
gros comme nouvel encadrement nice mais
nous devenons tous tes mots tout a été
dit youpi de dire la vérité complet un
débat presse que vous l'accusez demande
si etc
je vous ai fait grâce à la tour
notamment celle d'un vrai ce que et
encore des gens l'écoutent pour
seulement je pense que toujours des gens
à l'écouté quand un ministre se fait
qualifié de menteur et c'est ce qui
arrive actuellement ce pas une question
de sémantique ou de malentendus là
monsieur monsieur robert j'avais dit ça
a été validée quand on dit valider le
sauveur des cas c'est la santé publique
était d'accord et donner le feu vert
or c'était pas vrai mais vraiment pas et
là non seulement c'est un peu vrai mais
là avec les
le papier de corent gerber courriel là
on voit tout le tordage de bras qui
convoyait pas à l'époque que le ministre
de l'éducation a essayé de faire sur sur
le ministère de la santé sur la santé
publique
là c'est plus du tout la même chose là
c'est une interférence directes
grossières dans le travail des
fonctionnaires d'un autre ministère
alors là ça ajoute au dossier lourd
demain je dirais oui je pense que les ja
sont sont encore à l'école par journée
donc ça affaiblit encore plus le
ministre c'est assez facile de savoir si
un ministre est affaibli vous avez juste
à regarder l'opposition quand il étire
groupe et de l'opposition sur un
ministre parce qu'il est en position de
faiblesse un ils ont tendance à sentir
l'odeur du sang puis au delà du débat
sémantique on peut ramener à une idée
toute simple voulait pas parler aux
scientifiques vous voulez les écouter
c'est ce qui compte c'est ce que vous
faites avec la vie qu'il vous donne puis
moi ce qui me surprend même dépenses
dans l'attitude du bliss possible du
sous-ministre ans il faut pas l'oublier
c'est comme si ils avaient peur de se
faire critiquer pour des problèmes mais
qui pour lesquels il était de toute
façon pas responsables qui les
précédaient c'est pas eux qui ont créé
la pandémie c'est pas à cause d'eux que
les écoles sont dans un état lamentable
qui est des problèmes de ventilation et
quand ils ont voulu rassurer la
population mais la pire des manières
avec la méthodologie à la même façon de
rassurer les gens c'est d'être
transparent
oui j'ai encore une fois il n'y avait
pas avoir peur d'être blâmée pour un
problème qui était pas tout à fait là
bas en laissant croire qu'ils avaient
l'aval en fait la soirée one click
c'est ce cas il aurait pu mais pas dire
ça du tout en fait
et dire tout simplement les classes sont
encore ouvertes messieurs dames
stéphanie grammond mais en fait moi ce
qui me frappe c'est tout là toute la
lenteur de ce processus là sur la
qualité de l'air dans les écoles depuis
le début parce que évidemment le
ce dont on parle aujourd'hui c'est un
élément mais en fait les tests qui ont
été faits non seulement il était
critique i'm en plus ils ont un effet
mal fait donc d'une école à l'autre les
résultats étaient étaient différents et
on se retrouve aujourd'hui à la fin
lorsque la cloche la fin de l'année va
sonner où on sait toujours pas
finalement ce qui se passe
alors que l'été dernier on savait déjà
que c'était un enjeu donc c'est un
problème
merci beaucoup j'aurais pas t'en dire en
quoi vous êtes champions pas de journée
ça va être la prochaine fois
les courriels qu'ils veulent pas changer
grand chose pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit